So if you're anything like me,
there's a good chance you got so caught up in the everyday business of life and Father's Day
just sprung up on you, and you're not prepared, but don't worry because I'm in the same boat, and for this video,
I'm going to show you a quick and easy way you can still save the day by making your dad an awesome looking shirt
and tie out of money. Now for this tutorial
I'm gonna use a $20 bill and you can see there's a light green side and a darker green side,
and I personally like the darker green side for my shirts,
it just looks a little bit more classy and if you want to do the same start with that side facing up then take the
bottom edge and
carefully fold it up to meet the top making sure the corner is lined up, and then giving it a crease with your thumbnail.
Using your thumbnail is going to make that crease really nice and solid and once you've got that set,
you can go ahead and open it up with the crease side facing up.
Let's go ahead and take the other edges and fold them into the middle.
[ MUSIC ]
Let's go ahead and flip the bill around, then take the other bottom edge and fold that up to meet the middle again.
Now go ahead and unravel your bill,
and it should look something like this and the next step is going to be very similar to building an airplane.
We're going to take these top corners and fold them down into the center then use your
fingernail to go ahead and crease that edge over and
once that's set we're going to take the other corner and fold it down to meet the point on the other one,
making sure that that lines up in the middle as well,
and when it does we're going to crease that line to make a nice sharp triangle point.
Now when you've got the top of your bill folded into a triangle,
we need to go ahead and crease it down the center again.
We're going to focus on this edge right here because that's what we're going to use to make our tie.
Place one of your fingers on the inside corner of the triangle and then using the other hand,
fold it gently sideways and crease it off to the sides that's about half the width that you want your final tie to be.
Looking at it from this angle,
you should kind of get an idea of how this is going to come together.
Now once you've made that crease it's going to be really helpful just to flip it over and bend it back
the other way, and that's just going to help make that paper a little more flexible.
Unfold your bill back to the triangle position then take the bottom of the triangle and fold it inward,
increase it along the center now if you look very closely at the creases,
we just made you can see it resembles a tie
Now place one of your fingers on the right side of the triangle and then fold the tie in half and
hold that in place with your finger,
you can see how it makes the billfold off to the edge and we want to take your finger and
crease that down at that angle while we're here,
it's also a good idea to take this bottom corner and fold it up to the center and
come out to look very nice like that.
Now just to give you a quick replay on that this bottom corner here
goes up to touch the middle when we make that fold and
everything lines up with that fold that we made earlier.
Once you've got that set you can take your little tie flap and fold it back on top,
exposing the other side of the tie, and then we're just going to repeat that process on the other side this time
we're going to fold the tie in half from the other direction and use your left finger to hold that in place,
we're going to use the other finger just to gently smooth down the bill at the top there and
once again take this corner and line it up with the center now,
this really is the trickiest part so I'm going to show you one more time how it works just so you get it,
but this corner down here needs to end up in the middle and this line here needs to transition to go vertical.
So when we fold that vertically you can see how that corner transitions up to meet the top and
everything aligns with that side fold.
Now with that second fold may we can go ahead and unfold the tie,
and you should see that it sticks out on top of the shirt now. The next step is to make the collar.
To make the collar we want to focus on the very bottom end, take about a quarter of an inch
of material and fold it straight upward,
and crease it very nicely and then go ahead flip the whole thing over.
This will be your pointed part at the top and the flat part at the bottom.
We're going to start with this bottom right corner and fold it in at an angle so that meets the middle line and then do
the same thing with the left side grab the bottom right corner,
and just guide that corner right into the center at a bit of an angle, and this will leave you a long narrow strip.
Now flip your bill over the other way then grab the
left-hand corner and fold that in so that it meets the corner from the other direction,
hold that in place with your finger, and then go ahead and crease it so that it matches.
What this does is create the neck and the collar of the shirt, and you'll see how that comes together in just a minute but for
now flip it over so that the tie side is facing back up then take this collar and fold it up so that it hangs
just underneath the tie by about three millimeters or so, and crease the bottom to lock it into place.
Now this next part is going to be a little bit tricky as well because it's going to be where we form the arms.
We need to just tilt the collar forward so we can see this crease line on the inside,
we're going to pull that crease line out and recrease it the opposite direction and then fold the collar back in.
Now hold the collar gently in place with your thumb and grab the sleeve and gently pull it out until it's about the size that
you want. When it is go ahead and crease it down in place, and you've got one sleeve for your shirt done,
we can move on to doing the next one the same way:
gently pull the collar forward look for that crease line
pull it out and pinch it, so that's the opposite direction,
gently replace the collar in the center with your thumb and grab that other sleeve and just pull it out until it's about
where you want it, and go ahead and crease it in place, you might even want to put it down the table and just flatten everything.
Make sure it's about as secure as it can get. Right now your shirt should be looking something like this,
and if it is you want to flip it over and lay it down on the table with the flat side facing
up and we're going to take this bottom part with the shirt sleeves and fold it up to meet the shoulders on the back of
the neck here. When those two points align, crease it at the bottom
to secure it, then take the collar and fold it up so that it meets the top of the shirt,
but before you crease it turn the shirt over and just make sure the top of your tie
lines up with the collar first, if it does then use your fingers to pinch the back of the shirt
maybe put it on a table and
crease it as tightly as you can and if you've done everything right the back of your shirt should look something like this. Now
there's only one step left to finishing up,
and that's to take the collar and fold it over and around the front of the shirt.
That'll help lock it in place and hold everything together and just like that your little money shirt is done,
with the three dimensional tie and little sleeves that stick out.
So now you know how to turn any dollar bill into a cool-looking shirt
and tie that your dad is going to love this Father's Day.
And if he doesn't then don't worry about it because he can still use it to go buy himself something else. Well guys, thanks for
joining me for this video, and I'll be looking for you the next one. Talk to you then, and happy Father's Day, Dad.
I'm going to go put this in the mail for you right now.